[Music]  Alex Rodriguez gets put in the hot seat  on the view Friday about his budding  romance with Jennifer Lopez au and JLo  or an item says if I caught you j-rock  now it's safe to say things are off to a  great start for the new couple  he's just been super loving and  supportive the former New York Yankee  couldn't stop gushing over his superstar  girlfriend who he's been dating for a  month we're having a great time she's an  amazing amazing girl one of the smartest  human beings I've ever met and also an  incredible mother a rod even revealed a  few things we might not know about JLo  including her guilty pleasure she's just  like simple things I mean she's a very  very simple person who loves families a  great sister it's a great daughter she  would tell me if I say too much better  about my food Joe's chocolate chip ice  cream  [Music]